bienvenue à paroles autochtone 6 et
mélissa mollen depuis cette semaine
d'une question de lily qui me demande
quelle est la place des autochtones dans
notre système politique
c'est une excellente question puisque le
monde se demande ce soit mais comment
vous faites entendre par le provincial
fédéral
comment est ce que vous faites respecter
ou écouter vos droits
dans l'esprit de la loi sur les indiens
ça devrait être le gouvernement fédéral
qui prendrait soin de nos droits de nous
des choses qui nous regardent
on s'entend que ça n'a pas été le cas et
que présentement c'est qu'il n'a pas été
un très bon père de famille plus qu'on
est encore sous la loi sur les indiens
je parle pour les indiens inscrit son
rôle de protecteur ou de personnes qui
regardent au bien-être des présentations
a été très négligents ou même des fois
carrément dangereuse qu'on pense au
pensionnat à la rave des années 60 et
d'autre d'autres pratiques qui ont été
très difficiles pour l'identité
l'histoire la langue la culture est
juste même le bien être moral des
premières nations
cependant on a quand même les organismes
qui existent pour protéger nos droits
pour nous défendre face aux tirs aux
enjeux qui nous touche piqué qui sont
particulièrement imposées par les
gouvernements
je pense à la pnq elle qui est
l'assemblée des premières nations du
québec et du labrador qui vaut être une
assemblée des chefs de chacune des
communautés qui vont promouvoir le
respect des droits de respect des
ententes qui va défendre nos droits pour
tout ce qui a un rapport à la vie sur la
réserve il ya d'autres organismes qui
existe aussi en milieu urbain je pense
au regroupement des centres d'amitié
autochtones au québec et aux 4 à vers le
canada parce que la paix est mutuel et
le regroupement des centres d'amitié
autochtones se sont au niveau provincial
mais c'est des organismes qui existent
aussi au niveau national alors que vont
promouvoir le droit d'aider des
communautés autochtones d'avoir des
soins qui sont culturellement sécurisant
de pouvoir accéder justement du logement
d'avoir des cours de langue
m dans les milieux urbains présentement
il y en existe à montréal à val-d'or à
chicoutimi à sept-îles et ça est
vraiment les jeunes qui sont les jeunes
et les familles qui sont hyper mobiles
qui vont aller sur une communauté
pendant six mois vont aller aux études
pendant un autre six mois vont être tout
le temps un peu partout donc ça va
toucher à plusieurs niveaux de droits
autant le droit du citoyen normal
d'habiter à montréal d'avoir accès à des
services autant ça va toucher le droit
d'un été inscrit sur une réserve d'avoir
accès à des services donc nos paliers de
gouvernement qui existe dans les
réserves qui existe dans les communautés
au niveau organisationnel vont beaucoup
faire de la défense de droits auprès des
gouvernements fédéral provincial pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore un palier
gouvernemental autochtone qui existent
au même niveau que le provincial et le
fédéral pour parler uniquement des
enjeux autochtones qui sait peut-être
que quand la loi sur les indiens vont
être enlevées quand toute l'idéologie de
la tutelle et que les territoires vont
être données aux communautés qui sait si
on va pas développer un système
politique autochtone qui nous ressemble
et ça ça va être difficile puisque
chaque communauté chaque nation aux
défauts du système politique qu'ils sont
distincts les uns des autres et je
rentrerai même pas dans le fait que de
plus en plus de candidats autochtones se
présente au niveau politique fédéral
provincial municipal vont défendre les
droits des peuples autochtones en même
temps qu'ils vont défendre les droits de
citoyens québécois canadien c'est une
nouvelle pratique faut pas oublier qu
autrefois le fait de faire ce genre
d'implication politique nous enlever
l'identité autochtone enlever le droit
même d'aller vivre dans ta réserve donc
ce n'est pas des pratiques qui étaient
valorisés mais de plus en plus des gens
s'identifient justement cette pratique
là et vont utiliser tous les outils qui
vont être en leur pouvoir pour pouvoir
défendre le droit des peuples
autochtones
merci beaucoup les vis de la question
c'est une question d'envergure j'espère
avoir pu y répondre clairement et avoir
intéressé sur le sujet n'hésitez pas à
nous envoyer des questions n'hésitez
surtout pas partager le vidéo souhaite
une belle semaine